à l'annonce des résultats des accolades
et des applaudissements le chef de
l'autoproclame république populaire de
deniersk fin même le soulagement selon
les autorités séparatistes prorus la
population de la région de denisque
vient de voter à plus de 99 % en faveur
de son rattachement à la Russie
nous en avons rêvé en 2014 et nous avons
agi après cela marquant l'histoire
c'est donc un jour historique
nous retrouvons notre grande patrie la
Grande Russie
des résultats à sens uniques également
dans les trois autres régions dukraine
contrôlaient totalement ou en partie par
la Russie et les forces prorus selon les
commissions électorales locales le oui
l'emporte à 87% dans la région de Carson
à 93% dans celle de zapporigia et à plus
de 98% dans le louancek devant les
Nations Unies mardi le président
ukrainien vole au dix meilleurs Zelinski
a dénoncé une véritable farce
démocratique
les gens sont forcés de remplir des
papiers devant les caméras de télévision
sous la menace de mitrailleuse
les chiffres des prétendus résultats du
pseudo référendum ont été tirés au sort
à l'avance désormais il revient au
Parlement russe d'entériner
l'intégration de ces quatre régions qui
représente un cinquième du territoire
ukrainien comme en 2014 avec la Crimée
Vladimir Poutine pourrait ensuite
prononcer un discours dans les prochains
jours pour annoncer et formellement leur
annexion